foreign
good afternoon everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today
is SCP 5138
object class
safe
special containment procedures
[Music]
scp-5138-1 2 and 3 are stored in
individual medical stasis Chambers at
site 93 with an additional three
chambers held in on-site reserve for any
additional iterations that are found
the misinformation project establishing
the existence of a hitherto unknown
group of indigenous peoples around the
Louisiana bayou has been largely
successful Foundation construct
frederick.aic has been tasked with
maintaining the digital aspects of this
campaign and has so far removed any
opposing speculation from non-official
sources
additionally all reports generated by
Frederick AIC regarding any new
sightings of the Louisiana Bogman are to
be classified L2 5138 and forwarded to
the current
scp-5138 head researcher for
investigation
description
scp-5138 refers to a collection of
anomalously preserved humanoid corpses
pulled from the Louisiana bayou south of
New Orleans over the course of 15 months
three iterations of scp-5138 were
recovered and are being held in
Foundation containment
catalog number
scp-5138 1. acquisition date 8th of May
2012.
description
scp-5138-1 consists of a head thorax and
portions of both Sinister and Dexter
brachial limbs the thorax shows signs of
extensive damage to its lower portion
consistent with violent separation from
the remainder of the cadaver in a
non-anomalous corpse the State of Decay
is such that it would be believed that
this was likely the cause of death
catalog number
scp-5138 2. acquisition date 21st to
February 2013.
description
scp-5138-2 consists of a thorax and both
sinistral and dextral upper limbs in
Toto similarly to
scp-5138-1 the damage to the lower
portion of the thorax is evidence of a
violent separation between upper and
lower portions of the cadaver catalog
number
scp-5138 3. acquisition date 13th of
September 2013.
description
scp-5138-3 consists of a head thorax
abdomen pelvis and portions of both
sinistral and dextral upper limbs while
the abdomen remains intact the lower
limbs appear to have been surgically
removed prior to the subject of a
sepulture
while all three
scp-5138 objects are capable of
semi-autonomous locomotion the act of
such motion has caused significant
damage to the remainder of each object
due to their overall desiccated State
additionally
scp-5138-1 and
scp-5138-3 are capable of minor
vocalizations though they have yet to
produce anything intelligible
attached to denda discovery all three
iterations of scp-5138 were recovered
from a region in the Southeastern
portion of the Biloxi State Wildlife
Management Area in Saint Bernard Parish
Louisiana baited two assets within the
Louisiana Department of Wildlife and
Fisheries responded to an inquiry by the
swma Rangers to possible criminal
activity in the lake burgney area and
were able to recover iterations 1 and 2
with minimal intervention
scp-5138-3 was recovered several months
later after a news report was released
in the Gambit a local alternative weekly
publication in the New Orleans area
foundation AIC flagged the article and
forwarded it to site-93 where it was
reviewed by site Administration and
mobile task force beta 2 agent Christoph
melancon was assigned to investigate
5138 document 1 acquisition interview
transcript
date 13th September 2013.
agent Lieutenant Christoph melancon
interviewed Clancy dubo Gambit weekly
staff writer research object
scp-51383 acquisition
forward the following was recorded by
agent melancon's personal recording
device and is Audio Only agent melancon
posing as a detective with the New
Orleans Police Department had been sent
to interview Mr debeau at his home
regarding the article in the Gambit and
to ascertain the legitimacy of the claim
begin log
thanks for agreeing to see me see me Mr
dubo call me classic
everyone else does perfect I'm surprised
you would ask me to meet you here and
not the paper's office it ain't every
day a member of the John dollars was big
with me sure it ain't the first time or
nothing but you know
plus you said you was wondering about
the bog man so I figured it'd be best
just to show you so you have it here
why didn't you just turn it over to the
morgue for the folks over at Tulane
they'd be better to confirm your claims
oh yeah sure the lame boys will be
around eventually but I wanted to see if
there was a reward or something before I
just ham my prize over too
well that's the thing you see I never
heard no bog man in the U.S
so by the way exactly no bog yeah I
didn't know they could do that to nobody
this is why you're here first make sure
ain't no foul player or nothing well I'd
leave the specifics to the coroner I'd
have asked him to be here if your
article is mentioned the possibility of
a crime
you said mogman though and mummies
typically aren't the coroners area well
like I said I might get something for my
trouble where did you say you found it
well my cousin he got himself an airboat
and he lets me forward from time to time
out doing some brine fishing near the
Biloxi management area and I found it
out there
sticking up out of the mud ugly as you
please
right so instead of calling someone you
just brought it back here hey I had in
trouble or nothing am I I don't called
you guys but none of y'all will believe
me so I wrote the article and now you
send it someone called me it isn't my
call Clancy next time
just like one of the Rangers know before
you go disturbing this site okay
so show me this thing I got it out in
the garage it started stinking something
fierce in case you didn't want it in the
house
so I had this big ass cooler for fish
right big enough for a small grater if I
catch one I always wanted to catching me
a gator never did that
Jesus Christ what the
end log
afterward Lieutenant melon Khan reported
that
scp-5138-3 had pulled itself out of the
ice chest and had crawled across the
floor towards the garage door where it
attempted to grab at dubo's leg when
Lieutenant melon Khan pulled his sidearm
and discharged it at the
scp-51383 subject it ceased moving long
enough for a team to arrive and secure
the area Dubose and his wife were
amnesticized and the Gambit issued a
retraction of the story the following
week
additional research
scpf internal email
from F tomlier at site 93 scpf.int
2. s Arthur at site 93 scpf.int
date 11th of October 2013.
regarding scp-5138
finally gotten the time to review the
scp-5138 objects and I'd like to take
the opportunity to give you a brief
summary of my findings test is the full
review but the short version isn't
really less complicated obviously we
don't get bog mummies quite like this in
Louisiana there are quite a few still
being found over in Florida but the
conditions of the peat bogs over there
are such that they are much wetter than
the bogs where preserved bodies like
this would be found
for the most part there are more tissue
and internal organs don't survive the
mummification process in Florida bogs
though the skeletons themselves are
remarkably well preserved though even
with the preservation process you get in
much colder climates like Denmark you
typically don't find bog bodies in such
a well-preserved state that they
actually try and talk back to you
all three
scp-5138 objects create extremely
localized fluctuations in the Hume field
which is to be expected for partially
animated corpses what's more interesting
is the Trace Amounts of a kind of
radiation that accompany each optic
while there is not enough to signify
that these were ritually sacrificed
there is definitely more than what you
find in a Type green transformation and
the near total lack of any pharmaturgic
residue rules out at type blue entirely
this led me to get in touch with one of
our Assets in LaRue granted most of the
weird we find in the bayou can be
traced there but it never hurts to be
sure she was extremely reluctant to talk
about the goings-on of the leadership of
LaRue but she did glue me into some of
the missing Global occult Coalition
agents in the LaRue area
regards Franco tomlier MD PhD site 93
senior researcher
5138 document 3 classified L4 5138
on the 12th of October 2013 Dr Arthur
accessed The Joint Foundation GOC field
database and was able to confirm through
existing DNA records that the scp-5138
bodies were the remains of Special Agent
James Blount
scp-5138-1 special agent Robert Craig
scp-5138-2 and special agent Seth Avery
scp-5138-3
all three agents were involved in a GOC
task force assigned to the New Orleans
region that had been ordered to gather
intelligence on how to infiltrate the
LOI 504 LaRue macombra Nexus
while the exact date of their
disappearance is not available the last
update to any of their folios in the
film database was in January 2012
listing all three members of the
five-member task force as on assignment
the locations of Special Agent Brian
Silverton and agent in charge Andrew
Fort are currently unknown
update 410 2014.
on the 9th of April 2014 the Oriole
orbital Recon array detected a
significant spike in Akiva radiation in
the Biloxi Wildlife Management Area a
mobile task force beta 2 Bayou boys task
force was sent to investigate the area
and report back on any findings
the following is a transcript and still
from the footage recovered from Sergeant
Nicholas arnaud's body camera
date 9th of April 2014.
exploration Team Mobile task force beta
2 gamma Squad team members Sergeant
Nicholas arnaud team lead PFC Ellsworth
Montpellier and SPC Augustine Baptiste
control Dr Franco tonley
forward the team was airlifted into the
area by helicopter and dropped several
hundred meters from the location of the
Akiva Spike this transcript is taken
from Sergeant arnaud's body cam with
irrelevant portions removed for brevity
begin log
I got some
got some looks like a body my body's
reading 1.3 so I'm betting this was
where the spike was
all right I'm coming up bad keep your
eyes out and down what's it body we're
gonna get Gators oh no it moves up to
stand beside Baptiste and a small area
of dark mud can be seen in the
foreground the head arms and upper torso
of the body can be seen sticking out of
the marsh
control
I think we just found agent Ford
Frederick AIC has returned at 81
probable on facial recognition life
science It's Time by Arnold stands
forward and the view tilts as he leans
down and places his fingers to the side
of the body's neck negative no pulse
he breaks off and
with the body's eyes open
for me that's not a court of search
there wasn't a goddamn pulse control
please be advised this thing is looking
at us the body begins to shift slightly
in the mud as if it was attempting to
free itself
my legs stand clear or not beta Squad is
on route for Recovery herd control
you want me to talk to this thing I
can you
sergeant
please help me
I don't want it
dog
a little late for that buddy how can it
Baptiste
Ford
is that you
yes I'm the Ford
it's special operations
what happened to you Ford
the Nexus
that much oh there's a shot Joe's always
seemed to take kindly to people that try
and get in and kill this film so he just
kept me around for a bit
beautiful amazing he tortured you
I don't I never remember all of it to
tell okay buddy
I'm gonna help get you out of the mud
just hold tight delay that Sergeant beta
teams on their way
the bodies are up to 1.5 control things
are stabilizing and I don't like leaving
a guy stuck in the mud like this yeah
fine be careful any blips on your meters
and you get out
I know it moves forward to step behind
scp-5138-4 he reaches down and grasps it
under its arms
okay Ford I'm gonna lift on three see if
you can kick free of the muck okay okay
I'll I'll try nothing I don't know it
counts to three and then pulls but
stumbles back almost immediately he
falls to the ground causing
scp-5138-4 to fall out of the view of
the camera oh that that Sergeant what's
happening your heart rate just spiked
hard and I don't have a clear view
everything came out of the mud easier
than I thought
his ribs
end log
scp-5138-4 was recovered by the beta 2
Beta team and contained along with the
other
scp-5138 instances in order to maintain
operational security surrounding the
agreement between the foundation and the
administration of the LOI 504 the global
occult Coalition has not been notified
the location of Special Agent Silverton
is still unknown
Dr Stanley Arthur the current site-93
director requested an interview with
Person of Interest 504l Papa legba
Person of Interest 504l agreed to a
meeting and the two of them scheduled to
meet in one of the private dining rooms
at Antoine's a local fine dining
establishment in the French Quarter
date 15th of April 2014.
interviewer Dr Stanley Arthur
interviewed Person of Interest 504l Papa
legba forward when Dr Arthur arrived as
scheduled Person of Interest 504l was
already there stated at the only table
in the private dining room an array of
small dishes covered the table including
a bottle and two wine flutes the
following was captured from a hidden
camera and Dr Arthur's spectacles
begin lock
good evening Mr legwell thank you for
agreeing to meet with me of course Dr
Arthur would want you to be thinking I
and I are being rude we as ourselves in
agreement doctor I will oblige you the
meeting yeah unless we show off a bit I
was wondering why you chose to meet beer
and in a private room though old man
Elke of tour and I was friends you see
when he was setting up we helped him and
get his off the ground got him things he
couldn't get nowhere else we'd still be
supplying a lot of the eats here so I
get this table of my leisure he gestures
around at the empty room and the Privacy
that comes with it I appreciate the
gesture Mr legba I just don't understand
why you're making it ah you ain't gonna
like when you come here to learn I see
so you know why I asked you to meet with
me I've been knowing that and more that
y'all don't be known enough to ask this
year's my home doctor let me know when
all this goes on so you know about
scp-5138 then you thinking the damn
Gawker boys are the first group of Patty
rollers cut trying to get into the roof
you best disabuse yourself of that right
now
he's in the first sure ain't gonna
be the last
you condone Joe's actions and think
about condolences
Joe's been protecting LaRue since before
you jailers set up shop anywhere since
before this was the land of the free and
the home of the brave and all that and
nonsense it wasn't free then
free now
I see no you don't
how could you it was all sitting pretty
over there in that compound years you
ain't about to worry about no collar
going about your neck you'll be one of
them to put Scholars on next
we do what we must to survive dog
even if that means making deals with the
Devil Himself isn't that what Joe is
the devil
you deaf as well as blind Joe date the
devil dog
you is
end log
[Music]
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to zargaron
baked sip
oh crap guy
the Morrigan
James Saba
Irish wristwatch
Lost Boy
sagnar
your local Foundation agent
zazapan
worthy fire
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
Dean dingus
that loser
casadia cams
braided Peach
GM's right
Rowan O'Brien
cake neck
Grim near
extra moments one two three
and Swift Raw
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you
foreign